léonard pour défendre cette institution
cette police républicaine que vous avez
salué dans son quotidien et que nous
saluons tous ici il faut aussi être
particulièrement exigeant
il faut faire en sorte que chaque faute
et il peut y en avoir
chaque accès chaque mot y compris des
expressions racistes fasse l'objet d'une
enquête fasse l'objet d'une décision
fasse l'objet d'une sanction et je suis
sur ce sujet intransigeant parce que et
l'exigence que nous avons vis-à-vis des
policiers qui faudrait c'est garantir
justement la sérénité du travail de
l'ensemble de la police et de la
gendarmerie
c'est garantir la défense de cette
police républicaine qui au quotidien
combat combat le racisme combat
l'antisémitisme et s'engage au quotidien
pour défendre l'honneur de la république
c'est ça qui est essentiel il ne s'agit
pas de faire des amalgames mais il
s'agit effectivement de dénoncer tout
propos ou tout comportement s'il ya
faute
elle doit être sanctionnée et elles sont
sanctionnées